djaq Adcock was 6 years old when he died
from undiagnosed septic shock at
Leicester Royal Infirmary junior doctor
hadiza Barra Garber was convicted of
gross negligence manslaughter for
mistakes she made in his treatment but
today she was cleared to return to
medical practice Sky News was with
Jack's mother Nicola when the ruling was
handed down absolute joke so where's the
public confidence where does that leave
people where's the patient's safety so
my son died due to neglect from her and
she's allowed to go back to a hospital
with a gross negligence manslaughter
charge and treat or the patients
absolutely disgusted what happened here
in 2011 has had far-reaching
implications and raises profound
questions of medical ethics chiefly this
how should doctors be held accountable
for their errors and should anyone with
a manslaughter conviction be allowed to
return to work dr. barber Garber's
backers say she is truly sorry and the
decision is the right one she spent many
hours trying to prove herself look into
the errors that she did make apologize
to the Adcock family for her role in
what happened but she wasn't the only
one on duty that day and the hospital
has a lot of accountability here the
case galvanized support from junior
doctors who say that wider pressure on
the NHS contributed dr. Barbara Garber's
mistakes it's tough to see so many
doctors rallying around a doctor who's
been convicted of a crime but that's
because when you look more closely into
the crime you can see the factors that
led to this happening and a lot of
doctors feel like they've been in that
situation trying to provide that care
dr. Barwick Garber has made no comment
but last year after she successfully
appealed against being struck off she
said this I hope but I will be given the
opportunity
to do what I enjoy which is looking
after sick children and
I know that the lessons that I've learnt
from Jack's death will always make me a
better doctor for the Adcox promises
will never be enough
they might say we're going to retrain
her she might become a better doctor
would you know what she's been given a
second chance where's my son
dr. Barbara Garber will return to work
under supervision next year
Paul Kelso sky news